so this video is slightly out of the
ordinary I went to Disney see recently
or actually first three weeks ago now
but yeah I went to Disney see where it's
edy front to your fame who is on holiday
in Japan or at least he was at the time
when I recorded this and I'm studying in
Japan so these were just about the
perfect circumstances for us to meet up
in Disney sea and explore what is really
one of the best theme parks in the world
I think and the rest of this video is
pretty much just going to be our
afterthoughts I didn't vlog anything
during the day itself aside from some
b-roll which I will be showing along the
video but the focus here will really
just be our jumbled incoherent mess of a
love letter to - Park is so amazing so
yeah I hope you guys will enjoy this and
I'll see you in a second
hi everybody we just came back from
Disney see in Tokyo basically I am
currently studying in Japan as you might
know and and is currently on vacation in
Japan so we thought it would be a really
cool idea to meet up in Disneyland okay
cuz you see actually and go to a
and Japanese theme park yeah which is a
whole different experience it's yeah
we're winning for the traffic lights to
actually get green because we're walking
back to the station because we're quite
cheap but yeah we're recording this in
hindsight's you might be able to tell us
evening right now but I'll probably put
this in the beginning of the video
that's a bit of an intro I just kind of
forgot to vlog during the day it was
just too much fun and too much it's
green too much stuff happening
throughout the day but I'll show you
more of this and what I think of the
park and why DisneySea is such an
amazing park it was really good yeah we
talked some highlights now yeah sure
what is some of your personal highlights
my personal highlights were there waving
people oh yeah yeah there's lots of
waving people who in the cashiers who
just wave relentlessly just in case
you're looking is it that there's a
better survey if they get they get your
attention
then they'll they're just happy and the
waving at you remains then you go over
and buy some ice cream or it's just like
because Pacific it was so
be polite
the whole thing just feels like an
extension of that for actual serious
highlights included
okay in order oh yeah right yeah yeah go
ahead
Indiana Jones hmm dark right yes that
way Indiana Jones dark right
no yes I just totally respect that
I don't think that I've ever been on I
don't think I've been on a dark ride
until I'm gonna no I'm joking but I
think
the quality was just so high then
Journey to the Center of the Earth I can
totally respect that
again super high quality and a lovely
exciting punch at the end yeah I did
think about Disney see was that there
wasn't and that for me I like a thrill
ride hee hee there wasn't that much
if you're looking for if you look to the
thrill-seeking place I think the little
the places in Japan that but surely just
in terms of beaming it's just so strong
and we were so strong we were somewhat
unlucky because raging spirits the
roller goes through was closed today
yeah okay so everything just like the
lot of shows that we went to the show at
the end it was just outrageous in terms
of the quality level and just like full
a tiller of boats yeah ships though just
like firing fireworks over to the end
giant inflatable planets and then it's
too much like a dragon that comes out
that they then below what yeah it's just
n it's a combination of everything that
the show is caught Mike confess make
which i think is a some sort of like
weird connection between fantastical and
yeah
orgasmic I guess it's a it's really cool
it's like a combination of everything
it's got dance it's got boats it's got
fireworks it's got lasers water jets so
really really magical show there but I
also thought if the popcorn is good fun
yes it is a different flavored popcorn I
knew you don't usually get a piece of
pop you don't get usually popcorn like
that in the UK at least anyway
chocolate layer popcorn yeah everything
and also every vendor was was completely
as in only sold the one item yeah and so
then you have to go to the special
offenders and the key was really long
for the vendors yeah those interestingly
because we barely waited in line the
whole day for any right we managed to
get fast passes for just about
everything except for Toy Story Mania
Toy Story wait mania we waited for 80
minutes a little bit less and the rest
was just clean walk on and we did every
single ride that we wanted to do in the
park yeah that said I will say today was
not a very busy day so then it
definitely helped I also like the castle
area
there's a whole theme about the things
Adventure is the Society of adventurers
and it was showing off one of the things
that they discovered a clue didn't suit
aful room with corona coriolis a
cover the name of the relating the
planets order yes the star in the center
he could move the planets around
individually on this huge
she's beautiful just move the massive
display of the buttocks basically
I'll try
but yeah the weird thing about this is
there I'd say oh yeah definitely get
down there if you can make it to Tokyo
Japan
yes you know because I we already think
that Tokyo was a bit like a theme park
already for me mmm because everything is
so magical and different and and weird
and strange and like anything I've ever
seen
so actually going to a theme park within
a theme park is a really strange thing
also felt like Japan's version of an
American theme park yeah I can totally
see that because what's interesting
about the park for those who don't know
it's it was started by Japanese
companies but they approached Disney for
it so I think there's a real Japanese
sense throughout the park and it's in
everything it's like the way that the
staff is super polite welcome waving I
said the way I said the waving at the
star is a kind of joke but the way that
they welcome you on to every single ride
yeah as you come back in they all smile
and wave as you as you as you get off
the ride and thank you so much and and
it I think it's just an extension of
that Japanese culture but it's yeah it's
just an overall Japanese and it's also
in the way that all the people in this
park they all bring out their business
in eyes wearing the Disney hats
yeah fully embracing that this needham
if I can say that and there's just a
very unique atmosphere in this park that
I think it's just typical to Japan yeah
have you point any point
well about the yeah about the bride the
hospital so
Susy Azzam and the rhymes especially was
on Tower of Terror the last bottle
method their way that they were so
screaming with some chattering and yeah
it's just added a certain charm to the
whole experience I can totally see that
yeah and any more ideas any more final
words on DisneySea and I don't think of
the things I found interesting
on a reliever they've had some strange
fried banana oh yeah we had a fried
burrito with banana and caramel fry
burrito yeah it was good though yeah and
this was just a snack for lunch we had a
we went to a pizzeria at the near the
entry no I still recording and then
there was a and then this is the
there the pizza was fine that's all say
about the pizza it was fine like I mean
Jeff Japan no Japanese food well I
haven't had any other real any other
casino than Japanese position to be it's
been interesting to see what they of
other people's cuisine but causes yeah
that was in an area this thing drive and
it's that's interesting thing to talk
about the theming yeah because as you
mentioned earlier to me that it's very
subtle there are no and you taught me
this word weenies no ease well there are
some but it's more subtle that you the
changes into the different areas and
like the Steampunk area and it just sort
of got blends really nicely into this
arabesque area yeah super lovely and it
doesn't feel overly Disney fight it
doesn't feel like there's too much
Disney being shoved in your face which I
think can get a little bit irritating
yeah and it's also interesting that like
the main rides such as Journey to the
Center of the Earth or 20,000 Leagues
Under the Sea
are there more like a bit a little bit
like less well-known movies they're not
really big well-known Disney franchises
so it's it's a bit different in that
sense as well idea what I think says
well about all this
animatronics game on points yeah and I
never seen
we tie a bow these feel by the move
like there's juice into the earthís
spoilers this is credible way to station
creature at the bottom yeah all of its
pieces are moving it's huge it's about
the size of a tree yeah and then also
the Sinbad once in my Bridal yeah I
wanted to give a shout out to that one
so cute for the localized sound and the
attention to detail hundreds of Milan
electronics for those of you who have
been to
and also Jeb like very japanish very
cute oh so so such a cute version of
that sort of thing
yeah just and like I said but locally
sound like the sounds came from the
areas where they'll make it it wasn't
like cooked out food big speakers yeah
all the sound came for so small the
singing it was coming from there that
like Medtronic was so smooth well well
done see Disney see I definitely agree
also last shout out to the curry that we
had in the even was some really good
Indian curry I've only tried Japanese
curry before so it was really nice to
finally have some Indian curry it's just
overall I think for me everything about
this park is just really good it's very
well rounded the scenery is great the
food is good and I I would say overall
the atmosphere is yeah I mean it's the
best looking debug of a beam by only one
tiny grind that's because it's my
personal preference is that small all
right so be good by me
it's a very young park as well isn't it
yeah and also you know how pinky for me
to say no it's just not that kind of
park no that is true
although I do wish we were able to ride
the roller coaster I still had an
amazing day and for what it is I don't
think there's anything like Disney see
in the world listen there's no place
where this much focus on the scenery
atmosphere that you find over here
go with what he says yeah if you're ever
able to visit this me see if you're ever
around the area and you're even remotely
into theme parks definitely go here it
means an amazing place three-two-three
overall yeah there you go exactly let's
in Tokyo it's quite convenient very
close to the sensor opposite an hour
yeah it's like 45 minutes from Shinjuku
Station so really awesome well I think
we'll end the video with that's yeah so
thank you guys for watching thank you ad
for an amazing day well I really love
today a great company said to me and
just as we were leaving he said this is
normally what
which is the last Hawaii that is very
Clyde
[Laughter]
so thank you guys again for watching and
see you guys in the next video which
hopefully is going to be some planet
coaster stuff again because I definitely
want to pick it up again after being in
this park very inspirational bye bye
guys bye bye guys